Good morning Starshine.
Flower Beauty foam primer, I think yes.
♪ My money don't jiggle-jiggle, it folds ♪
Like, how satisfying.
How to solve any Rubik's cube.
You have the ability
to influence the world in many ways.
Ways that could be great.
And ways that could be ugly.
Now we see that there's
an ugliness to this,
all I ask is do the right thing, TikTok.
Do the right thing.
TikTok is one of the most
popular social media platforms
that exists today.
Almost 70% of kids between
the ages of 13 to 17
are on TikTok on a daily basis,
using it more than all
of those other platforms
that have existed in our lives.
One of their greatest strengths
is that it's so popular for kids,
but that has also become one
of its biggest weaknesses.
Not only do you have some
of the youngest users
in the world of social media,
we are also seeing content
that is proliferating through the app
that can be potentially harmful to kids.
We're seeing disordered eating content,
we're seeing posts about
suicide and self-harm.
We're also seeing dangerous
and, in some cases,
deadly challenges.
I'm so protective of the outside.
I never thought I'd have to
be protective of the inside.
A social media app.
I never thought in my mind-
Right.
That that could ever result
in me losing my daughter.
I am here because I don't
want any more children to die,
I don't want any mother
or father to feel the pain
and the heartache
and the brokenness that
we feel every single day.
Because this is hard.
One of the biggest issues
that TikTok is facing today
is the blackout challenge.
This is a challenge where
children are choking themselves
until they lose consciousness,
and then filming the
adrenaline rush they get
when they wake up.
This game involves individuals
holding their breath.
We have seen a number of children die
participating in this challenge
across the United States,
and also around the world.
Families are suing TikTok
after eight-year-old.
Now, we're seeing lawsuits
being filed against TikTok,
raising the question
of who is responsible,
who is liable for these deaths?
The only thing that's
certain about this case
is the incredible opposition
that we're going to face
at every step of the way.
The last thing in the world
these companies want to do
is stand up in front of a jury
and explain to them why their
profits were more important
than life.
Our entire society is bleeding
and our children are dying,
and unless we do something to change that,
this is going to keep happening.
My question to TikTok is,
what are you going to do?
What are you going to do
to change this platform?
Because at this point,
it's not safe for anyone,
and it's definitely
not safe for any child.
For the last 25 years,
my practice has focused
on compensating victims
who are injured by corporate misconduct.
I've recovered over a billion dollars
on behalf of families
who've lost loved ones.
Most of my cases have
involved asbestos victims.
I wanted to do something not
simply to compensate victims,
but to see if I could use the legal system
to have less victims in the first place.
Frances Haugen released her papers
on what the social media companies knew,
and that reminded me of what
the asbestos companies knew,
only worse.
The choices being made inside
of Facebook are disastrous,
for our children, for our public safety,
for our privacy, and for our democracy.
We can have social media we enjoy.
We can do better.
These companies make
the asbestos companies
look like choir boys.
These companies know that
children are being injured
as they speak, right now,
and more importantly,
they continue to target children
through their algorithms.
The goal is to addict
children to their products.
Children are being
directed toward material
that they don't want to see
for purposes of engagement.
That's what these algorithms
are designed to do.
The Social Media Victims Law
Center is based in Seattle.
It's a small team of lawyers
that are taking on the biggest
companies in the world.
Filing cases against
social media platforms.
Their cases include suicide on the apps.
Children who have attempted
the blackout challenge
and tragically died.
Or kids who have been sent down
eating-disordered rabbit holes
who have ended up in hospital
over the content that
they have been served
through TikTok and other platforms.
What the center is
really hoping to achieve
is to push social media
companies to accept
a level of responsibility over these cases
and put children's best
interests in front of profit.
Corporate misconduct is knowingly putting
profits over people.
It's knowing that your products hurt kids
and knowing that you
could make them better,
and intentionally making
the decision not to do so,
because it would impair their profits.
That to me is corporate misconduct.
I think that as long as
you have a profit model
that is built first,
last and in the middle
on user engagement above
and beyond all things,
I think it's inevitable
that you're going to have
these kind of hazards and
these kind of outcomes.
My clients feel like
if, through this effort,
one child is saved,
then it's been worth it.
We're in Milwaukee, Wisconsin,
and I've come down here to talk
to the family of Arriani Arroyo.
She was a nine-year-old
girl who loved TikTok
and in February last year,
she was trying the blackout challenge,
and she tragically died.
Earlier this month, July of 2022,
her family filed a wrongful
death lawsuit against TikTok.
I think the question of
responsibility and liability
of these social media
platforms is a really big one,
and I think this family is
wanting to raise that question.
What kind of liability does TikTok have
when it's young users try
these viral challenges
and they have fatal consequences?
It seems like a really
nice, quaint, suburban area.
It's so sad.
Eggy.
It's time to eat.
Oh, I brought you a napkin.
Give me that one.
Mom, I want a cookie.
You have that.
Is it warm?
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
That is good.
Hmm?
It's good.
I love you.
Good boy.
Arri, she had this
personality that wasn't afraid
to take on the world.
She wasn't afraid to take on a challenge,
she wasn't afraid to do whatever
she felt she wanted to do.
Yeah, she loved to sing in her room,
and, I mean, you can hear
her sing out her lungs,
just singing Alicia Keys,
"This Girl Is On fire".
That was her song.
It was, I mean, over and over,
you could hear her singing her lungs out.
She was just so beautiful,
too beautiful sometimes.
I think we live in such an ugly world
that she's too beautiful.
Why do you think TikTok
was so intriguing to her?
I go back to the dancing and the singing,
and it was not just that.
All her friends, all her peers,
everybody's doing the trends, it's on TV.
TikTok was for everybody, and
it wasn't just a kid thing,
it was an adult thing,
it was a teenage thing.
I mean, it was just a known app.
She's nine years old.
She's still a little kid and curious.
We talked to her many times
before about things like that
and we've also even warned her of things,
so we thought we were on great track.
It's not something that we
would say would be any harm
or dangerous to her.
It's a phone.
Right.
Do you know, prior to her death,
how long she'd spend on TikTok?
Every day.
Every single day.
Passionate.
Don't care about what the
other people say about you.
Be confident and be passionate,
because everyone in this
world is beautiful, so.
Social media challenges
really started spreading
throughout the pandemic,
when kids were unable to be in school,
they were in isolation at home
and they were turning to social media
to connect with their peers.
And we saw some really
cool challenges pop up.
But as is always typical
when kids are involved
and when social media is involved,
some of these challenges
started to get edgier,
they started to get a bit more dangerous.
I was doing the Crate Challenge.
♪ Left foot, two stomps ♪
♪ Slide to the left ♪
In January, 2021 we saw the first death
associated with a challenge
called the blackout challenge.
Individuals holding their breath...
This challenge has existed for decades.
Now we have children
filming themselves doing it
and it's spreading across social media,
which is encouraging some
of the youngest users
on the platform to try this game
or this challenge without
realizing that it can be deadly.
This is Arriani right there.
That's her.
I wear this with me on most occasions.
You think of the happy moments
you think of the beautiful memories
but the fact that you're never
going to create them again.
We're all just very broken as a family.
You know.
Arriani Arroyo was playing
with her four year old brother
when she accidentally hanged herself.
She'd been asking her parents for months
to get a dog and they'd finally agreed
and they'd bought a metal dog leash
to show their children
that they were willing
to get a puppy.
And Arriani and her brother were playing
with this dog leash.
She wrapped it around her neck
and hooked the buckle onto
the hinge of a wardrobe door.
She then slipped off a toy
chest and couldn't escape.
Their dad then came upstairs
and saw Arriani lifeless.
He called the paramedics
but sadly she never
regained consciousness.
She was buried in a tiara
and a fairy princess dress
with her nails freshly painted.
Her parents believe
that TikTok's algorithm
fed the blackout challenge
to Arriani on her cell phone.
We are not living, we are surviving.
Because every day we wake up
and we are not hearing
her say, I love you.
We're not hugging her,
we're not holding her.
And anybody that has to go
through what we've experienced
that's what's going to be the outcome.
And we're here to make sure
that there is education.
Where in God's name did you think
that putting a rope around your neck,
a chain around your neck,
is something wise to put out there?
And reality is, I feel that like everybody
they should be held
accountable for their actions.
My daughter is gone, other kids are gone.
There's darker sides to TikTok
than what they're exposing.
Why did you decide that you
wanted to file a lawsuit
against TikTok for wrongful death?
Well, first, yeah, they're responsible.
I feel that they're responsible for it.
Second of all, we need to, right now
we need to save every other
child that's out there.
They need to make changes
because other kids can be
still vulnerable for this.
I think it's really important to remember
that TikTok doesn't want the
blackout challenge to exist
on its platform
and it has taken steps to
try and remove content.
So way back in January of 2021
after the first child's death was linked
to the blackout challenge
and connected to TikTok,
the company decided to scrub the ability
to search for blackout
challenge content on the app.
They have updated their
community guidelines
to say they ban any kind of content
that glorifies dangerous
or harmful behavior.
They've also trained their moderators
to look out for blackout challenge
or other dangerous challenges
that are spreading across their sites.
They are removing this content.
But despite all these safety measures
the deaths kept happening.
We found that the blackout
challenge was cited
as the cause of more than a dozen deaths
of children throughout 2021.
And I think the biggest legal question
for all of these lawsuits
that we are seeing coming up
in the courts today is,
can you prove that TikTok's algorithm
sent that blackout challenge
content to the child's phone.
This is her chest where all her,
some of her stuff,
this is her birth announcement.
These are her third grade-
That's right.
Photos.
I know it's been almost two years
but it just still feels like yesterday.
It just,
it's a feeling
that just takes the breath out of you.
It's a heaviness on your chest.
Grief is so hard
and everything I do is just like,
really reflects off of what I
feel she would want me to do.
And I really believe that this fight
is 'cause that's what
she would want me to do.
And that's why I'm fighting
for her and all these kids.
Because I believe that's
what she would want.
So TikTok was created
in 2016 by ByteDance.
A big company based out of China.
It actually took a while
for it to gain traction.
It wasn't until 2018
that TikTok really blew up
and that was because ByteDance
bought this lip syncing
app called Musically.
And at the time, musically
had about 200 million users.
Many of these were under the age of 13.
This violated the Children's
Online Privacy Protection Act.
Which is a law that says
children under the age of 13,
you can't collect their data.
In order to abide by
all of these regulations
TikTok has created a version of its app
in the US that is targeted to kids
under the age of 13.
And it's called TikTok for younger users.
It really tailors the content
to be suitable to kids.
And it doesn't target
them with advertising,
but kids know how to get around it.
They just enter the wrong date of birth.
TikTok will tell us that age assurance
is an industry wide issue.
But in the last year we've
seen a number of companies
partner with third party
content moderation providers.
What these providers can do
is run machine learning
age prediction models
that isn't collecting any
data on the individual.
It doesn't raise privacy concerns
but what it does do is
estimate how old that user is
and is highly efficient.
I sent a video of Arriani Arroyo to Hive.
This is one of those
artificial intelligence
content moderation companies
that does age prediction
for other big platforms
like Twitter and Reddit.
And it took Hive's technology
three seconds to estimate
that Arriani was 10 years old.
She died just three months
shy of her 10th birthday.
TikTok has also met
with these third party
content moderation providers.
They ultimately decided not
to deploy this technology
because there were fears.
It could stoke further suspicions
around China spying on young users.
Wow, okay.
Is that something that you can share?
What I'd say,
is that the way these
products were designed,
it was impossible for parents to exercise
meaningful oversight of their children.
What's occurring now is
what an economist would call
an externality.
The costs of these unsafe
social media products
are borne by parents,
they're borne by teachers,
they're borne by law enforcement,
medical providers, psychologists, clergy.
The costs are not being borne
by the entities making the product.
We think that product liability
provides an independent way
to hold these companies accountable.
Not for publishing third party content
but for designing
algorithms that hurt kids.
If they actually have to pay the cost
of their dangerous products,
they're going to have
the economic incentive
to design safer products.
Cars are a lot safer
than they were in 1950.
They're a lot more safer
than they were in 1980.
And a big reason for that is
that the concept of product
liability creates the incentive
on automobile manufacturers
to think proactively,
to design safer products.
And it is our hope
that the same thing can be done here
and that five years from now
children will be having positive
experiences on social media
and that these horrific
outcomes like Arriani Arroyo
will have stopped.
This whole situation has placed us in a,
you know,
everything's almost like red flags.
You know, Eduardo going to school again.
He's going by himself.
It's another thought.
We don't know what the
long term effect is on him.
You know, you're doing the best you can
and that's all you can do.
That's all you can do.
Yeah.
And you know, we've got
a long road ahead of us
but we've already made a difference.
And you've already made a difference.
You've already blessed a lot of people
through her memory.
I think it is the most
innate human emotion,
is protecting your kids.
These were parents that thought
they were doing the right thing.
Thought they were being responsible.
And then just the profound guilt
that these parents are
feeling is unfathomable.
♪ Like a highway ♪
♪ She's living in a
world and it's on fire ♪
Fix the cross and her-
Yep.
Hi baby.
That's my baby.
Social media has been designed
to put things out there
to put content out there,
to make kids believe
that either they're not enough
or they're not good enough.
Or they have to be this way.
♪ In hopes you're on the other side ♪
♪ Talking to me too ♪
These challenges
I feel just manipulate
the mind to think like,
if I can conquer this,
if I can do this, you
know, I have purpose.
You don't need none of that,
to have purpose in life.
We need to, as parents,
remind our children
what purpose is and and help them
and direct them to finding
their real purpose in life.
Because social media is not it.
♪ At night when the
stars light up my room ♪
♪ I sit by myself ♪
These social media companies are giant,
billion dollar Goliaths.
And they will all claim that safety
is their number one priority.
But when you speak to insiders,
to those who work on
trust and safety teams
tasked with keeping these platforms safe,
the message I hear time and time again
is that user safety is not
the number one priority.
That growth is the number one priority.
Making more money is
the number one priority
and being the biggest app
in the world is the number one priority.
That's true of TikTok
and that's true of other
social media platforms as well.
As we've seen more and
more children be harmed
through social media, we
are now starting to ask
have these companies been doing enough?
Do they really want to protect
and keep their users safe?
Or are they just doing the bare minimum
to avoid being held liable
against existing privacy laws?
Children have been dying
using these platforms
and these questions aren't going to stop.